[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the new hulu film fresh
starring sebastian stan who plays steve
and daisy edgar jones who plays noah so
this film i went in blind all i did see
was the trailer for it which was a
freaking amazing trailer if you've seen
it props the editor of that trailer for
this film it is so good will make you
want to see the film but they say
there's this big twist and halfway
through so that got me wanting to see
this and what would this become right
i've never seen anything with daisy
edgar jones so i was excited to watch it
for that reason i've heard only good
things i have not seen normal people
i've only heard good things but she
totally lived up to the hype for me she
was so so good
and i also
might be my favorite performance of
sebastian stands here uh i've seen him
as stuff i haven't been totally sold on
how good of actors yet but this really
sold me i thought he was great
and that's the thing about this film a
couple highlights for me were just on
the base level the two powerhouse
performances by these leads were great
also in the acting terms of this film
the actress who plays the best friend
molly was also really really good i love
when you see an actor for the first time
for me at least and
you are just like who is this person
because even in a role that's not even a
major role which becomes a big role as
the film goes on but she's just really
really good you kind of could just tell
when someone has it and she definitely
has it so it's always exciting to see a
new face that just crushes here and what
also stood out was the cinematography i
was really down with the director's
choices of how they framed certain shots
i love how even just when we first saw
the character of noah getting drugged
the slow
out of focus change from her point of
view nicely moving into her being fully
out of it which sometimes people can
rush out or can come off silly i liked
her use of extreme close-ups i thought
they were all at the right beats and
that moment she would pull us further
away from
steve uh from noah's perspective when it
got more distance and scary and
more intimate like the scenery eating
dinner just all really clicked in that
sense visually however
this film is one of those films that
i thought the script was really good the
first 30 minutes and i think there was
an anticipation knowing there'd be a big
twist right so i was really hooked from
the first 30 minutes the two of them
have great chemistry and i was like okay
what's the big twist i'm excited you
know what's gonna happen here i thought
it took its time but i was still sold
because i was enjoying the chemistry and
how it was working up to that and
then what's bizarre which i didn't
expect about this film was that once we
got the big twist it really wasn't that
big of a twist it's something we've seen
a lot of times before it kind of just
becomes a hostile film
but it just got kind of boring you know
there's really not much to it than that
like it got boring and that's something
that could be a problem with the script
for sure where it's just kind of
thin you know ironically it's a movie
about meat but there wasn't much meat to
this script at all it kind of just
becomes a series of really nice shots
really good acting but
not much plot happening here uh and it's
tough in hostile type movies like this
where someone's trapped and it's like a
double-edged sword with how they did it
because then the film's really shot
from an objective point of view so it
makes you kind of question is noah
really following for steve and becoming
this monster or is she playing it out to
fool him and just being smart because
she knows what he wants like the dancing
and the sex and wearing the dress which
was a nice payoff from the beginning
date scene even so
you know it turns out yeah she's a smart
playing him which you could figure out
easily that's pretty obviously
predictable but because it went with
that objective root it might have
suffered that it wasn't subjective from
noah's point of view and these tense
moments and what she was thinking i kind
of missed kind of being in her head but
it was there to kind of make a suspense
that
you know yes you're wondering what's
really going on here what she's really
plotting
but i don't know if that was enough to
sacrifice maybe could have been more
interesting from just her perspective
now i like the twist that the wife was
in on it with steve i took it as if she
was a former victim
that the clear was showing that half her
leg was off and that
she had probably been eaten by steve and
that she was someone who did the
opposite the end of the day then noah
and converted to being someone who was
like they say
the woman who is the worst that kind of
enables a man like steve you know that's
in the film but also metaphorically
correct me if i'm wrong though if that
had nothing to do with her you know
actually confirmed she was ever a victim
for him that's how i read it it was
interesting these clients
that steve were selling to
not only ate these women but they had a
particular fetish where they had a
picture of them their name would sniff
their bra that was interesting that felt
a little more different i like a lot of
foreshadowing they had where even in the
beginning when they're in the grocery
aisle and they first meet noah and steve
they have the sign fresh meats behind
her they're showing meat being chopped
up from the beginning they show meat
being hung in the beginning and there's
little lines even like do you want
something to eat or drink and steve's
like nope just you so they're giving you
a lot of that and you know doesn't help
someone like steve that another steve
character is a total creep and weirdo
just just not helping my name
i know that's a random thought but i
just had to get off my chest one of the
better scenes at the later half of this
film is when she is really eating this
meat now and the way daisy edgar jones
has to stand out more she's like i just
feel awful i don't feel awful really
fooling steve here and she plays on
again
that feelings he had for her that he did
have sex with her and he didn't with the
other woman and she played it perfectly
she was smart character which i liked
and she bites his wee-wee off which was
pretty insane now where it kind of gets
too familiar stuff of recent times is
just on the nose stuff like
when she shoots him and she says come on
give me a smile referencing to how he
talked to her that come on give me a
smile thing where a guy talks to me like
that it's just been in so much stuff now
you saw it in captain marvel i have
nothing against it but again it's when
you're making a point like that it's so
on the nose you know like just do it in
a way that's more
profound with showing than telling with
a simple line like that that's just kind
of too easy for me that's like
just
so surface level where you want more
into that so that kind of felt a little
repetitive things we've seen recently
where i would like that kind of shown
more in a unique way i like to end it
with the shot where it's on the phone
where it's a text from you up with chad
and again the film does a good job of
showing you that struggle with modern
dating today and that metaphorical part
of it about woman and how men treat them
and how they should stick together and
it's scary how you really can't even
trust strangers especially the online
dating too
and the woman like the wife who enable
men like this in this type of behavior
it's just to an extreme extent with the
eating of people i like that they had
sebastian stan being this character who
loves to dance that was a nice tick they
added to him but with all this good
stuff i'm saying again what really hurt
is just the interest part of it the
pacing it just is too damn slow in the
middle here and it's really slow up
until that last eating scene it's just
kind of plotting along and it just
needed more plot and i i just think it
did suffer because it wasn't totally
from her point of view during the whole
time in captivity and i get the decision
it makes sense to keep that mystery up
of what she was really planning but i
think that hurt it more than did good
for the end of the day i mean there's so
much potential here i think there's
potential for this director and the
cinematographer i'm excited to see what
they do next this seems like a nice
plate like a base that's like okay this
was their okay you know movie they did
but something better is down the line i
see super potential for this director so
i like that but you know the other day i
look at this film as great
cinematography
great great two lead performances and a
great performance by the supporting
actor who plays molly so it's just
suffering from an empty plot with not
enough meat to it has good ideas has
good themes but again even some points
like i said with the smile line it could
be a little more unique and more of
something outside of the box and
something we've seen just put on a plate
everywhere so i'm giving this one a 6.2
let me know what you thought of it down
below i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment try to respond as
many as i can please make sure to
subscribe it helps me in so many ways
you have no idea it would really really
help me currently in my life it just i i
can't even explain put into words it's
just so
great if you do it and i'll be so
grateful please follow me at steve
harley show on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me and i'll see
you next time